انا
[موسيقى]
هدف صعب لاصحاب الاموال يشتعل الجدل حوله
خلال الازمات الماليه العالميه فهل ندخر
ثرواتنا بالدولار ام الذهب
فرصه لتحقيق ربح راسمالي بالاستثمار طويل
الاجل اي شراء الذهب وتركه حتى ارتفاع
اسعاره ثم بيعه لتحقيق الربح من فرق سعر
الشراء والبيع يعد الذهب اقوى الملذات
الامنه اذ يحافظ على الثروه عند وقوع
ازمات التضخم وتاكل قيمه الدولار لكنه
يصنف من الاستثمارات قائمه على الخوف اي
انه يحفظ الثروه لكنه لا يضاعفها مثل
الاستثمارات الاخرى
رجال العالم يرفض الاستثمار في الذهب لانه
لا يضر عوائد ويضخ امواله في الاسهم ذات
الاخطار المرتفعه والربح الكبير
[موسيقى]
الدولار يمثل نسبه الاكبر من احتياطات
الدول من النقد الاجنبي وتسعر به الاصول
الاساسيه مثل الذهب والنفط بالاضافه الى
صفقات الغاز والقمح والتجاره الدوليه وهذا
يجعله مقاوما عنيدا للازمات العالميه
باستثناء التضخم ويبتسم الدولار ايضا
بمزايا لا تتمتع بها اصول الذهب مثل
الحصول على عائدات من ايداعه في المصارف
وسهوله الانفاق والتخزين والشراء والبيع
بسرعه تحويله الى اسهم وعملات رقميه واصول
اخرى لكن نظره سريعه على المنحنيات
التاريخيه للذهب والدولار تظهر لنا ان
المعدن النفيسه اقوى كثيرا من النقد ففي
عام
1913 وهو العام الذي تاسس فيه الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي الامريكي بلغت قيمه اوقيه الذهب
20 دولارا امريكيا في حين تتجاوز اليوم
قيمتها 1900 دولار هل تفضلون الذهب ام
الدولار